qu'est-ce qui se cache vraiment derrière
toi Guillaume parce que j'arrive pas à
savoir c'est des gens très sympa
tu peux enlever les lunettes pour voir
déjà ouais
comme ça non enlève-le
en ce moment c'est pas de moi c'est ça
tient bien ouais c'est une très belle
personne que j'ai rencontré
en terminale non je l'ai rencontré sur
les réseaux sociaux et ça se passe bien
ça fait on se voit depuis 6 mois à peu
près c'est beau vous êtes super discret
ouais parce qu'une fois tu as même cru
que je te filmais avec elle je te
rappelle de ça
il a très mal pris alors j'ai jamais
voulu donner son identité mais pourquoi
tu es autant peur de ça c'est parce que
tu as peur qu'elle te parle parce que
c'est une personne que certaines
personnes connaissent et j'ai pas envie
de d'accord la notoriété pour aller
faire du mal au couple de quoi la
notoriété pourrait faire du mal au
couple non c'est une personne que des
gens connaissent autour de ce plateau
donc c'est on a regardé il m'a regardé
et elle a vraiment changé ta vie avant
tu étais un peu plus libertin entre
guillemets
quelque chose à lui dire tu lui dirais
quoi en deux mots bonjour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va d'abord il y a deux questions que
tout le monde se pose sur vous il y a
deux questions
transparence transparence la première
question c'est combien vous gagnez tout
le monde veut savoir
tout le monde
c'est quoi la deuxième question est-ce
que vous êtes en couple non c'est pas
mal là